a long time man even though you've been
doing this [__] too long you already
know man how are you doing though man
I'm so good bro I'm so blessed man I'm
so I'm just I'm lit right now I'm
excited man it's a lot going on team
winning we we moving yeah I mean I've
been loving working hard it's the output
of music thank you you've been putting
out music consistently but now Quality
Music which you've always done
throughout your career but I just you
know I feel like you just been on your
[__] Bro the last couple years like no
definitely it's definitely been like a
you know a building brick Brick by Brick
process you know to a bigger picture
that we have in terms of just like re
resurfacing the brand fully you know of
Mario do you kind of look at like what
happened because I feel like
when I think of the pandemic I think of
verses and when I think of verses I
think of a few things I think a Jadakiss
showing people that you really got to be
able to rap right and then I think about
you showing people
no you got to be able to sing if you can
hang with me like for real soon like you
you smoke the Marion in that verses
respectfully because Mario's a legend
but you smoked them obviously you gotta
hear records but you also were like
there's no Antics involved like I'm just
gonna say raw bro it's raw you know what
I'm saying the same way I came in the
game yeah I'm saying the same one I'm
just refined you know I'm saying the
same young dude y'all fell in love with
singing Just a Friend and break my hand
you like yo what why is this the 106 and
Park kid you know what I'm saying it's
just refined man and I think versus just
really gave me a platform to remind
people yeah what that frequency is you
you look at that moment as kind of like
because you were of course at the time
you were still doing your thing but like
do you think that that was a very
pivotal moment in terms of just
reminding people like hey don't forget
I'm here like of course because there's
so many eyes anytime you get you know I
think it was the biggest versus like in
terms of viewership yeah I mean it was
the biggest one and
I mean anytime time you get that many
people in one space and you're able to
shine it's it's a big look for you and
it it shifts like people's awareness of
what you're up to you know even though
they know who you are it's just it's
just awareness thing
um but I think it's like
yeah it put me back in a mental space of
all right like it's like now it's time
to like really dive in and start getting
back to the music you know and then
since then it's just been you know
ongoing has your creative process
throughout the years changed in terms of
like when you're in the studio how
you're writing maybe the environment
you're in like how has it evolved like
to where you are now for example with
main one right are we outside it's I
don't even know what was it like a
Friday or Saturday night Me Andy Dre
London the whole gang it sounds like it
was there it was like Andy was there it
was a great time it was it was we
outside tiger was outside and then we
literally just go back to the studio
Mike's in the room whaps everywhere if
you listen to his second verse you're
gonna hear like
it was just and normally when I record
I'm in a booth or sometimes I have it
out there because I Engineer myself but
like right when I'm working with people
I'm like I don't need my [__] to sound
it's spectacular so I'm you know I'm
gonna put my [__] in the booth but it
was just one and
that those types of moments show you
like it don't have to be perfect
Perfection is is what you focus on after
you get the Roses on Union perfected but
like the actual creative process does
not have to be perfect I feel like some
something it's just magic magic is Magic
some artists out think themselves for
sure I've been there
and then we don't get the music right
and then it never comes out and then
that's different we still don't have the
detox that that's that's that's funny
that's different though like I I
understand that it's like you wanna
when you talk about somebody like Dre
like that's like that's a lot of
pressures like you want to make sure
you're doing your best
your best work right and especially if
you're not releasing consistently it
gets harder and harder the longer you
wait to release the harder it gets to
pick that perfect record or that perfect
project and so I just been taking
chances lately and just having fun I
just feel like I'm having fun again like
this should be important that's the most
important we probably got into it let's
just have fun exactly no it's been it's
been dope to see